welcome back
i scared you i'm sure i decided
i have more energy but anyway i'm
actually fasting today but i won't go
into it too much but i i do this thing
well there well i don't want to go too
much into my personal life but i i've
realized that i i eat every i eat one
meal a day now and i have so much energy
it's unbelievable but anyway
i hope you don't think i'm crazy but
back to back to the sat back to the sat
videos
so let's see we're on problem number 15
problem
number 15. so i drew it all ahead of
time because i didn't want to waste your
time because it's more valuable than
mine i think
consider it because i have so much time
now that i i only eat one meal a day
they say in the figure above triangle p
q r so this is p
triangle p q r
is equilateral it's equilateral and s
r
s this is an s
s r
and and
t v
t
v
intersect at point p what is the value
of y
so let's just use all the information
that gives this is equilateral triangle
so what do you know about equilateral
triangle all the angles in an
equilateral triangle are the same this
is going to be 60 degrees this is going
to be 60 degrees and this whole thing is
going to be 60 degrees right
well if this whole thing is 60 degrees
then what's x well there's three x's and
they're equally splitting it right so
this is 20 degrees
and this is 20 degrees right
and angle y
well what's equal to angle y what's well
if from our geometry module we know that
angle y is opposite to is equal to the
opposite angle right angle y
is going to be equal to so we've got to
make sure you're just going to pay close
attention to which lines this
is
which so that that line and that line
right so the opposite angle to angle y
is this angle right here
right
so that angle is just two of the three
x's so it's 20 and 20. so y angle y is
equal to
y is equal to 40 degrees it just equals
two of these x degrees
that's it
all right number 16. maybe i could do it
here with this kind of toothpaste
colored
ink
let the operations triangle and square
be defined for all real numbers a and b
as follows
a i like these problems a
triangle
a triangle b
is equal to a plus 3 b
and then a
square
b
a square b
is equal to
a plus 4b
and then they have this thing if
triangle
of 5y
5y
is equal to
5y square
for
what is the value of y well this might
seem bizarre to you but we just have to
map these functions to and this is just
a functions in disguise right a function
of really two variables so let's say so
what is 4 triangle 5y so let's go to the
triangle function that's this one right
so in this case
a is 4
right because it's the number before the
triangle so that's equal to
plus
3 times b well what's b well b is
whatever's after the triangle right b is
whatever's after the triangle in this
case it's 5y so 3 times b would be 3
times 5y
3 times 5 y
let me do some
coloring here
this
is just this
right
and then if i do the other side of that
5y
square
4. so in this case 5 so we're using the
square so in this case 5y is a right so
5 y is a so that equals 5
y
plus 4
b
4. and what's b well b is whatever's
whatever's
the second
whatever whatever's after the rectangle
right so 4b so 4 b is 4 times 4. and now
we just solve so let's see 4 times
4 plus let me just rewrite that 4
plus 3 times 5 is 15y
equal to 5
y
plus
16.
let's take 4 from both sides so you get
y
equals 5
y plus 12.
take
5y from both sides you get 10y
is equal to 12
y is equal to 12
tenths and then we can reduce that right
divide the top and the bottom by two
so y is equal to
six
over five and that is our answer and you
can
these are these kind of fill in the
blank ones so you can actually write
that bubble it in the sat wasn't like
that when i took it i actually these
problems are really good
let's move on
image
image invert colors all right
number 17.
i'm going to switch to magenta
brighter magenta okay in the x y
coordinate plane the graph of
x
is equal to y
squared
minus 4
intersects the line l
at so it intersects the line l at
zero comma p
and the point
five comma t
right these are two points on the line l
what is the greatest possible value
of the slope of l
so this is interesting so
x is equal to y squared minus four so
this so first of all you need to realize
this isn't how you normally write a a
function right you normally write it y
is equal to x something
but what this is going to look like
x plus 4
is equal y squared well and you don't
have to draw this actually in the
in in the
in on the sat because it's going to take
you too much time but i think it's
useful here to have a visualization of
this right
and if you have a
see so the graph is going to look
something like this x 4 so
it's actually the negative it's going to
actually start at -4
it's going to
it's going to it's going to look
something like this the graph oh whoops
i'm still using the line
tool the graph is going to look
something like this it's going to start
back here minus 4 and then b
i think that's what we want and then the
line l we can only assume
since it intersects it at two points
it's going to look something like this
right where this could be 0 comma p and
this is 5 comma t what's important to
realize is that both of these points
satisfy this relationship right
both of these points because it's
they're on this curve they're on this
curve
so we can
do that with our math right we could
write this as
comma well if x is 0 what is y
well zero is equal to y squared minus
four
let me add four to both sides y squared
is equal to four
so y is equal to plus or minus two and
that's the tricky part right y is equal
to plus or minus 2
plus or minus 2.
and then what does this equal so if x is
equal to 5
what is t what could what could this
term
right here be so let's see 5
is equal to
y squared minus 4
y is equal y squared is equal to 9
y is equal to plus or minus 3.
so this is plus or minus 3.
fascinating
it's plus or minus 3.
and actually i i drew this this original
graph
since it's written this way since it's
not written as a square root it actually
would kind of do something like this and
where the
it would
i'd do a little funny but you don't have
to draw it's either so anyway this plus
or minus three
y so these are the possible uh two
points we could have intersected and
what the question is asking is
what is the greatest possible value of
the slope of l
well we want to figure out
well if if we want the greatest possible
value we want to go from a very low
number to a very high number right when
i mean these this the x values are fixed
but we want as great a possible change
in y given that change in x right
so if we want the lowest possible value
here we'll deal with the negative two we
want the highest possible value of x
we'll go with three
so let's see so if we assume that the
change in y is three minus negative two
over change in x five minus zero
this adds up right
so this three plus two is five or five
it equals one
that is the greatest possible slope i'll
see you in the next video
oh